[Music]
Esther our costume designer has just
been a great addition to the show she
excelled at this space suit I pretty
much looked at every space suit there
ever was both in reality and on screen
we were creating a suit that was
feasible that look realistic you overlay
all the needs of TV the specifics that
we need um it becomes a very complicated
equation you up for an adventure only
one way to find
out one of the biggest requests from
Matt and Ben was the actual weight of
the suit in season 3 the suits weighed
70 lb it's a lot our suits are working
suits they have to work work and they
have to look like they have some
function I was really happy with the
helmet it looks great from all angles
and that's a hard one to
do can I get one of those suits they're
all booked this is the only one I got
available from the planet Earth where to
our Mars habitat we're pushing over 500
fittings on cast so that's big it's a
lot of clothes we need to get this thing
done this asteroid it could change
everything for people back home the
challenge for me was to sort of set up
the Dynamics that were within the
written script we're seeing certainly a
lot more color in our professional crew
and then when we look at the Helios crew
there's much more utilitarian look about
them and I think it served the script
very well we spent the time and the
energy investigating all of our choices
and making sure they were the right
choices I need skilled people on my side
and you are very skilled
[Music]
indeed